Speaker 1: All right. We've spoken a little
bit before about the brewing war between MAGA
suck ups, Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert. Both are Republican members of the
House of Representatives. Both were reelected in
2022. Marjorie Taylor GREENE by an easy margin.
Lauren Boebert by the slimmest, slimmest slimmest
of margins, and increasingly they are at odds with
each other. We started seeing this a couple
of weeks ago, and I talked to you about it,
and now they are increasingly going after each
other in an ugly way, which I think we should
support now. There are people online talking
about, you know, cat fight and sort of all this
sort of stuff. That is really not interesting
to me. The fact that they are both women
to me is is not part of why this is interesting.
If Madison Cawthorn were still in Congress and
he was the one at odds with Boebert or GREENE,
we would be just as interested. The interesting
part is these cartoonish, vapid, ignorant do
nothing maga. People arguing with each other
is interesting because all they really have is
their allegiance to MAGA. That's I mean, listen,
if it weren't for Trump and if it weren't for
MAGA as something that they could say we support.
They never would have been elected in the first
place. And so it's interesting, as we see Trump's
2024 campaign get off to a shaky start, to say the
least. And we see questions as to whether or not
MAGA will eventually acquiesce and get Kevin
McCarthy elected Speaker of the House. It's
particularly interesting to see MAGA subdivide
and I'm going to go to a video yesterday. We
looked at some of this interview earlier. This
is the interview during which Lauren Boebert on
Fox News told Bret Beyer. Just like with George
Washington, if we decide Jim Jordan needs to be
the speaker, then he will be the speaker. She was
presented with some of the things that Marjorie
Taylor GREENE said about her. She then goes after
Marjorie Taylor GREENE It's getting very ugly and
MAGA seems to be subdividing. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Soundbites, Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
then Dan Crenshaw. Take a listen, please.
Speaker 3: Lauren Boebert under $2 million
from Kevin McCarthy to get elected. Many
more people have taken Kevin McCarthy's
money to get elected. And then there's a few of
them that don't want to support him as speaker.
Speaker 2: Some of the reasons that these
people have for not voting for McCarthy are
unbelievably petty. Unbelievably petty.
This is about showmanship. This is about
notoriety. It has nothing to do with the concert.
Speaker 1: By the way, the irony of Dan Crenshaw
saying others are being petty is not lost on me.
But it's I don't want to get derailed because
this is more about Lauren Boebert response,
which we're going to see here in a moment.
Speaker 2: To Marjorie Taylor. GREENE
Congresswoman, saying that, you know,
you just won a very close election in Colorado
and that went to a recount. And she's saying that
Kevin McCarthy helped you get across the finish
line and that you're just trying to make a point
or make a splash. How do you respond to that?
Speaker 3: Well, there are laws in this
building that prevent me from going too far
into detail. But I can say that I did not
receive any help in that election, and that
was a very big deal. We pay dues as members
to the NRA and they were nowhere to be found.
And then as far as our requests being petty,
I don't think a secure border is petty.
I don't think a term limits bill being
brought to the floor, not demanded to
pass, but brought to the floor. So we
actually have an option to vote on that is petty.
Speaker 2: But, Congresswoman, you're not saying
that your other colleagues you're not saying your
other colleagues don't want a secure border or
don't want a balanced budget. Right. You're not
saying that about your Republican colleagues.
Speaker 3: We haven't seen that demonstrated
from leadership. We asked for the I.R.S.,
the Republican Study Committee budget.
Speaker 1: All right. You get the point.
Lauren Boebert saying Marjorie Taylor GREENE is
straight up lying straight, just making it up,
whole cloth. The support that she received.
What is the future of this intra MAGA
spat or fight? I don't have the answer. But
one of the things that I expect to happen is
as Trump. And if Trump and MAGA continue to look
weaker and weaker and part of how we know this is
how are Trump's primary polls looking, including
against people like Ron DeSantis who haven't even
declared that they're running for anything? If
Trump looks injured irreparably, I think maybe
is the term we would apply to it. I think you will
see more MAGA infighting because they will realize
the Trump train, the MAGA train on which we even
came to power is no longer going to be the boogey
that keeps us afloat. If the allegiance to MAGA
is no longer the boogey that keeps us afloat,
what else do we need to or can we do to separate
and distinguish ourselves from the other people
who came to power on the same? Nothing that we
came to power, which was Trump was popular enough
at the time that by endorsing us and saying,
we love Trump, we were able to win. If Trump.
Surges in the polls and reestablishes himself
as the clear guy who's on his path to win the
2024 Republican nomination. I believe you will
see less of this infighting. It is a reflection
of the shakiness and the crumbling nature of
the Trump MAGA movement at this point in time.